horizon zero dawn is truly enormous
which if you've got the 40 hours to
spare is kind of an awesome thing given
its quite the undertaking though here's
a few things to keep in mind that should
help you out as you venture through the
post post-apocalyptic world
first up there are a hell of a lot of
things you can pick up and your
inventory is limited but you can craft
bigger carrying pouches for your various
item types if you're wondering which of
the many pack upgrades you should craft
I would seriously recommend getting your
resources pack as large as possible as
quickly as possible so check out what
items you need to collect to do so and
try to grab them give everything an
initial bump but beyond that you'll
likely be selling crap equipment mods or
swapping out your weapons for better
ones so you don't need the extra slots
on the other hand almost every resource
is a crafting item or a trading item and
you won't want to get rid of any just in
case you need that raccoon skin or watch
your learns later on pick up icons turn
red when you can't collect any more of
an item but things like branches are
unlimited so if you find yourself
carrying around 500 of them you might
want to drop some and make room for
other items in terms of exploration hit
all the campfires you come across apart
from being good save points they also
serve as fast travel points for when you
inevitably need to backtrack across the
continent for something fast travel
requires using consumable travel packs
but there is an item that lets you fast
travel unlimited times you should pick
this up from a merchant as soon as it's
available if you aren't a fan of walking
if you can't find it it's down the
bottom of their resources tab you can
and should buy treasure maps pretty
early on that will give you the
locations of different collectables
which you can trade in for treasure
boxes generally binoculars are found
high on mountains colored with bright
tribal markings to help you see where
the climber bulerías are metal flowers
are huge blossoms encircled in a ring of
nonmetal flowers and ancient vessels aka
mugs can be found in piles of ancient
debris both will come up purple when you
get close I'd recommend getting to the
middle of the area where the item is
supposed to be and flicking
you're focused then you'll be looking
for fuzzy purple areas if you're lacking
in loot grab extra loot perks in
scavenger skill tree early on if you
find that taking out machines for shards
becomes tedious no you'll find a lot
more simply by completing quests and by
raiding supply boxes in bandit camps and
towns your focus can help you find these
easier every merchant also has a free
sample box which you should totally get
you know because it's free in terms of
combat you'll mainly be scanning robots
for weaknesses and adjusting your
arsenal accordingly if you like playing
it sneaky you can perform stealth
takedowns from the relative safety of a
bush over and over and over again with
the laws skill result death pit it takes
some time but it's great fun the rest of
combat is really balancing and comboing
your skills with one another whether
that be a dodge knockdown and critical
hit with your spear or a time slowdown
concentrated precision shot with your
bow from the air every time you get a
new weapon you'll also get a tutorial
quest where using it in a certain way
will grant you a significant amount of
experience the problem with this is you
have to make sure the tutorial mission
is activated in order for it to register
yes
it's very annoying but now you know
there's obviously way more to learn but
hopefully these tips will alleviate a
few annoyances for all our upcoming
horizon content be sure to subscribe and
check back to GameSpot
you
[Music]